geht es ihnen auch so wie mir dass sie
sich wundern dass die parteien aus dem
schock ergebnis nichts gelernt haben vor
allem was das abschneiden der afg im
osten angeht sachsen wurde sie stärkste
partei aber auch in den anderen neuen
bundesländern schnitt sie
überdurchschnittlich ab warum der osten
so gewählt hat das erklärt uns der
renommierte politikwissenschaftler der
tu dresden werner patzelt und warum der
westen immer noch nicht kapiert hat das
sagt uns christoph schwennicke der
chefredakteur des zieht so
[Musik]
herzlich willkommen aus dem herzen
berlins ja man kann es kaum fassen
jetzt gerade wird hier am brandenburger
tor
die vorbereitungen abgeschlossen für den
tag der deutschen einheit wohlgemerkt
einheit als hätte man nie gewählt
letzten sonntag denn der osten hat einen
aufstand gemacht und der westen hat es
wahrscheinlich noch gar nicht kapiert
denn zum beispiel die erste reaktion des
bayerischen csu chefs und
ministerpräsidenten seehofer war
wörtlich das kann doch nicht wahr sein
dass es war es und warum es war es da
erwarten wir analysen unserer gäste
heute in dieser sendung ich freue mich
ganz besonders dass professor werner
patzelt da ist einer der renommiertesten
politikwissenschaftler was die lage die
seelenlage auch im osten angeht er hat
viel geforscht und er hat bereits 2016
in seinem buch gewarnt päda warnsignale
aus dresden herzlich willkommen so
patzelt und ihm gegenüber ein
streitbarer kollege aus dem westen
christoph schwennicke chefredakteur sei
2012 des magazins für politische kultur
cicero und hier bestens vernetzt auch im
berliner politbetrieb herzlich
willkommen herr weniger auf den punkt
gebracht spaltet diese wahl das land ich
kann euch gar keine spaltung erkenne ich
würde eher sagen da kommt wieder
zusammen was zusammen gehört nämlich im
nächsten bundestag meinungen haltungen
die das widerspiegeln was im volk
gedacht wird und deswegen ist das keine
spaltung sondern der bundestag der
nächste bundestag ist ein
repräsentativer spiegel dessen was das
land denkt ja spaltet dass das land sehr
osten fühlt sich ja abgespalten
der neue bundestag widerspiegelt die
spaltung die in deutschland da ist sie
ist nicht nur eine zwischen den
unterschiedlichen wahl gebeten west und
ost die wir ja seit der
wiedervereinigung immer unterschiedlich
kennen es ist ganz wesentlich eine
spaltung zwischen denen die die
einwanderungs thematik insbesondere mit
patriotismus nationalgefühl usw
zu tief zusammendenken und jene die die
sache negativ zusammen denken und diese
tiefe kulturelle spaltung die wir das im
bundestag zum ausdruck gebracht und das
völlig ist richtig so denn dafür ist ein
repräsentationsaufgaben und in dieser
ganzen stimmung feiern wir dann also den
dritten oktober dem tag der deutschen
einheit und das wahlergebnis hat
irgendwie gezeigt dass diese einheit
zumindestens risse hat der osten fühlt
sich allein gelassen und hat mit seinem
stimmzettel dem westen einen denkzettel
verpasst wir werden frau merkel oder
wählen auch immer jagen und wir werden
uns unser land und unser volk
zurückholen
die gewinner der bundestagswahl kommen
von rechtsaußen aus dem stand in den
deutschen bundestag mit knapp 13 prozent
der wähler stimmen
die die afg ins parlament ein ein schock
für die alteingesessenen parteien
sie wurden abgestraft gerade im blick
auf die wählerinnen und wähler der asd
ist unser anspruch sie durch gute
politik durch lösen von problemen auch
wiederzugewinnen zurückzugewinnen diese
große koalition an gestern 14 prozent an
wählerstimmen verloren ich glaube es ist
eindeutig dass die deutschen keine
fortsetzung der großen koalition gewollt
haben
wir führen das darauf zurück dass wir
eine offene rechte flanke hatten
die genutzt wurde im politischen
wettbewerb
besonders ostdeutsche wähler trugen zum
erfolg der fdp in allen neuen
bundesländern erzielte sie
überdurchschnittlich hohe ergebnisse in
sachsen wo die cdu 27 jahre durch
regiert hatte wurde die afg jetzt sogar
stärkste kraft und zufriedenheit und wut
sind spürbar
wir haben keine angleichung an
westdeutsche gesundheit alles hängt doch
hier in der luft die einwanderung in die
sozialsysteme
so wurde leute dort gestellt als wenn
hier not gümbel werden und uns muss man
alles erklären wie die politik läuft
jung ist niemand was erklärung laut zdf
forschungsgruppe wahlen ist der typische
afd wähler männlich zwischen 35 und 49
jahre alt die meisten haben mittlere
reife sind arbeiter 26 prozent männer
und 8 prozent frauen haben im osten für
die partei gestimmt
im mittelsächsischen örtchen
dorfchemnitz gab sogar jeder zweite den
rechtspopulisten seine stimme die
anderen parteien haben keine
veranstaltung gemacht sind nicht präsent
und wir sind irgendwo falls wir sind ein
bisschen was auch abgeschrieben die
kleinen dann immer weiter in rand
gestellt da gibt es kein mittel
damit sind die leute
die abwehr wackelt gab es wirklich keine
andere alternative denn diese stimmen
geben die eine stimmung wieder oder sind
das einzelfälle
diese stimmen geben eine stimmung wieder
die nicht auf einzelfälle sondern auf
kollektiven erfahrungen beruht es hätte
eine alternative gegeben sie gab es auch
lange vielen oder um die pds gewählt als
sie noch ein neues partei war
viele haben die cdu gewählt so lange
diese partei noch bereit war auch jene
menschen zu vertreten die nicht in der
politischen mitte steht und links
freilich auch nicht sondern klar recht
stehen all diese integrationsbemühungen
sowohl seitens der pds als volkspartei
wie auch der cdu ist eine partei auch
für den rechten teil des politischen
spektrums sind eingestellt worden aus
welchen gründen auch immer man hat leute
als dumm erklärt als rassistisch als
narzisstisch erklärt die einfach nicht
im mainstream schwimmen wollten und das
ist nun die quittung dafür viele haben
an diesen politischen system innerlich
gekündigt und nachdem das ja lange
vorhergesagt worden war dass es so kommt
wenn man sich nicht vernünftige
politisch verhält hätte es zwar eine
alternative gegeben aber am wahltag war
sie nicht mehr sie aber wir haben sie
beide eingeladen weil sie das fertig
gebracht haben
in zwei sendungen so sie vor vier wochen
ungefähr bei ihnen ist es schon ein jahr
her wo sie eigentlich schon die rezepte
gebracht haben wie können parteien jetzt
auf diese unzufriedenheit reagieren dass
das vielleicht nicht passiert ist das
die schuld der westlichen dominanz der
politik das würde ich so gar nicht sehen
es ist schlicht ergreifend so lasst
diese wahl ein referendum war über die
flüchtlingspolitik der kanzlerin und der
großen koalition da beißt die maus den
faden nicht ab und dieses referendum ist
im osten zu großen teilen zu gunsten der
afg ausgegangen aber übrigens im version
auch sehr starkes wollen jetzt nicht
unterschlagen und und im westen
vielleicht dann mehr zugunsten der fdp
es gab zwei parteien
außerparlamentarische
parteien die dagegen angebote gemacht
haben oder jedenfalls dagegen an geredet
habe ich würde sagen die fdp hat er noch
ein konstruktives angebot gemacht in der
migrationspolitik die afg hat vor allem
geschimpft aber wie auch immer
deswegen aber nicht dessen dass die eu
eine million an die haben doch alle
irgendwie spät also ein kurzer dauer war
es kam deswegen spät weil viele den
elefanten im raum nicht sehen wollte
weil die großen oder sagen wir die die
im bundestag befindlichen parteien die
meisten davon oder die meisten
protagonisten dieser parteien diesen
großen elefanten im raum wiedersehen
wollten noch benennen wollen das war die
migrationspolitik das war der
kontrollverlust vom herbst 2015 bis zum
frühjahr 2016 so und wenn die das
einfach nicht ansprechen heißt das ja
noch lange nicht dass es die leute nicht
umtreibt was treibt sie um und sie
erlebnisse in ihrem alltag und ich kann
übrigens ein argument nicht mehr
ertragen wenn gesagt wird gerade da wo
gar keine flüchtlinge oder außen sind
ist die ist der widerstand am größten
herne ich kann auch gegen oder für ein
tempolimit auf deutschen autobahnen
seien ohne autobesitzer zu sein ohne ein
auto zu fahren was vernunft oder welche
das sind gesellschaftliche kosten
entsteht ich kann das ich kann das was
sie tun und dass deswegen ist es auch
ein gutes recht von leute ja ihre
meinung da so ausdrücken und jetzt noch
ein wort zum westen also uns zu dem zu
herrn seehofer der so viele es
ausgestoßen hat wie edmund stoiber in
seinen verzagten zeiten in diesen tagen
herr seehofer hat in bayern mit einem
plakat der afg zu tun gehabt da stand
drauf wer csu wählt bekommt merkel und
dieses plakat hat gewirkt deswegen ist
die csu mit ihrer schwesterpartei cdu
abgeschmiert dem ist rundum zuzustimmen
schauen sie es wird er im moment das
argument angezogen die tatsache dass die
afg besonders dort stark geworden ist wo
die cdu lange zeit stark waren in
sachsen in bayern auch in
baden-württemberg zeigt dass genau der
falsche weg darin bestünde dass die cdu
für die rechten bürger da seid denn
dadurch würde man lediglich die afd
essen diese leute denken einfach nicht
den entscheidenden schritt weiter in all
diesen ländern deutschlands gab es
jahrzehntelang bürger die der union
vertraut haben dass sie für den staat
und seine kontrolle fähigkeit steht dass
sie für die finanzielle freiheit führt
auch der sozialstaat steht dass diese
partei dafür steht dass die im lande
länger schon bestehende kultur sich
nicht allzu schnell wandelt und auch die
zusammensetzung der länger schon im
lande lebenden bevölkerung sich nicht
allzu schnell und nicht ohne
einbeziehung dieser bevölkerung
verändert all diese leute hat die union
im stich gelassen und zwar ganz bewusst
im stich gelassen als die ersten sorgen
darüber betonen würden hat die kanzlerin
in einer berühmten neujahrsansprache
gesagt wer sich über zuwanderung und die
bewahrung der länger schon im lande
bestehenden kultur sorge macht der ist
jemand der kälte und hass im herzen
trägt und am schluss wurde das ganze
auch auf die kanzlerin hin
personalisieren und sie hat es was einem
jahr in der seele weh tun konnte auf
fehler marktplätzen quer über die
republik oder insbesondere im osten für
fühlen bekommen und das kann glaube ich
völlig unvermittelt also ich hatte den
eindruck da hat die cdu überhaupt nicht
gerechnet und der schärfste widerstand
war in rosenheim in bayern und dann noch
gekrönt in münchen als sich die gesamte
führungsriege der csu in die erste reihe
stellte und nicht hinter die kanzlerin
es war also schon fast symbolisch und
die pfiffe waren ganz vorne
damit hat man doch rechnet ja ja das ist
die autos suggestive kraft dessen wenn
ich etwas nicht wahrnehmen möchte was
eben fakt ist und die kanzlerin hat
viele talente viele gaben aber selbst
kritik gehört nicht dazu
sie hat ja und das wird auch diese diese
das wird immer schlimmer ehrlichkeit ist
ein normaler prozess glaube ich auch bei
amtsinhabern bei kanzler nur sagt das
auch cool war es genauso auch gerhard
schröder hat bei uns im heft vor einigen
monaten auch gesagt er ist für eine
begrenzung gut ich meinen hut ab
das hinterher sagt man man ist
irgendwann in dieser position fühlt man
sich allnächtlich und man man man dreht
ab jetzt meine soll
und wenn sie natürlich wollen sie es
dann nicht sehen und sie merken es erst
wenn die tomaten fliegen sie merken es
erst wenn die tomaten fliegen da ist was
da ist also dann lässt es sich eben
nicht mehr unterdrücken sondern dann
dann manifestiert es sich in form von
tomaten und pfiffen aber es sind doch
zwei mächtige der ost- vertreterin der
bundesregierung einmal die kanzlerin
selbst und dann der aus dresden
stammende de maizière hat der aus
dresden stammende de maizière ist im
grunde aber auch ein westdeutsches oder
unter westdeutschen system verhältnis
und sozialisiert es um dort seine
karriere machen das gewächs und die
ostdeutsche merkel ist überhaupt in der
politik unter westdeutschen bedingungen
sozialisiert worden so dass eine
wiedererkennung als ostdeutsche hier
nicht gegeben ist genauso wenig wie wir
einen bundespräsidenten gauck der gerade
im osten auf unglaublich viel ablehnung
dann bei den rechten gestoßen ist zu
sprechen dann vom bundesrat klar und
meinten dass dann auch was eigentlich
müssen möglich gewesen wäre seit der
seitens der kanzlerin deren und wirklich
eine tüchtige und erfahrene und kluge
frau ist das hat sie in der wahlnacht
ganz kurz in einem interview anklingen
lassen und einen teil dessen haben wir
ja vorhin gehört sie sagte natürlich
wissen sie dass sie selbst mit dafür
verantwortlich sei was der union wieder
fahren und der afg beschert worden ist
künftig müsse man die sorgen der leute
ernst nehmen
man müsse auf die probleme achten die
die leute vorbringen und man müsse durch
kluge politik diese probleme lösen aber
damit hätte man schon im herbst 2014
anfangen können und man hätte der ganzen
regina bewegung dem pdf de komplex seine
wucht weggenommen
aber damals war man zu arrogant wusste
sich selbst auf der seite der guten
die den schlimmen auch noch das licht
veröffentlichen gebäuden abdrehen und
auf die weise hat man genau jenen
widerstand gezüchtet der jetzt die cdu
sehr sehr gewehre mitglied der cdu wenn
wir mal kurz verraten fühlen sie sich
daran wohl schauen sie ich bin im jahr
1994 meiner partei beigetreten weil bei
vielen politischen
bildungsveranstaltungen ich das hohelied
auf die parteien gesungen habe und
gesagt habe wir tüchtig ist was kann der
muss
sind eine partei damit die demokratie
funktioniert und irgendwann fand ich bei
den nachfragen ob ich selbst war eine
partei wäre keine ausrede mehr
ein politikwissenschaftler dürfen nicht
mitglied einer partei sein ja eher
dürfte eigentlich gar nicht politisch
denken weil er sonst die aseptische
objektivität verlieren würde
da bin ich der partei beigetreten von
der 51 prozent der grundsätze teile das
tue ich heute noch in folge dessen gibt
es für mich überhaupt keinen grund aus
der eingeheirateten familie wieder
auszutreten aber der punkt ist der auch
in der union kann man sich mit
unabhängigkeit ist sehr wohl leisten
fehler die die kanzlerin gemacht hat zu
benennen und das tue ich und interessant
für den journalisten ist ja jetzt jesus
sagen wir durch journalisten gilt da ist
noch nicht nicht hat ja das würde ich
auch wirklich unterstreichen und sagen
umso interessanter ist es jetzt haben
plötzlich die medien schuld an allem
also dass die afg so hoch geschrieben
worden ist und so oft im fernsehen
vorkam als ob das dorothee wären von
denen das uba oder erkennt doch ursache
und wirkung gut also absurderweise hat
wiederum alexander gauland im laufe des
wahlkampfes einmal geklagt sie würden so
ja unterdrückt werden kämen in den
medien nicht vor
also die klar bestimmt genauso wenig wie
die andere klage tatsache ist doch ja
die afg vertreterinnen und vertreter
sind sehr viel auch in den talkshows
gewesen aber warum diese talkshows
werden noch nicht zusammengesetzt
nach dem prinzip wir machen das so damit
möglichst wenige zuschauer sondern
setzen das natürlich so zusammen dass
ich schauen
aha das zieht aufmerksamkeit auf sicht
offensichtlich ist möchten die leute
hören was sie zu sagen haben so also ist
das wird hier sozusagen der der boote
verdroschen für eine botschaft die ganz
woanders her kommt nämlich aus der
zuschauerschaft und das passt ja wieder
zu dem was ich vorhin gesagt habe dass
es wurde versucht zu verdrängen aber die
wirklichkeit ist so hat sich so
reingedrängt in diesem wahlkampf von
ende dann auch mit einer kleinen
hilfe gewissermaßen das ging jetzt
plötzlich nur noch um die sogenannte
dritte kraft wer wird jetzt die kraft
ehrlich gesagt eigentlich wurscht ist
nicht hoch geschaut hat sich
hochgeschaukelt und das hat der hatte ja
seit ihres themas noch mal zusätzlich
fragen wir jetzt mal die bürger und das
interessante ist wir fragen ja immer
rund um unser studio wir am
brandenburger tor
und das sind meist die leute die aus
bussen herauskommen die den bundestag
besuchen also die politisch interessiert
sind
was halten sie von der idee dass viele
ehemalige ddr-bürger sich vielleicht
mehr paradiesische zustände vorgestellt
hatten als die mauer fiel die politik
gehört da nicht so nach der wende eine
menge versprochen und generation die
jetzt da ist die fordert dass auch ein
bisschen eigen sind ja ein bisschen hin
gelassen worden wenn man so will von der
politik die rentner im osten kriegen
immer noch weniger rente als die im
westen das lohnniveau ist sich das
gleiche das ist auch eine quittung sonst
wäre es vielleicht bei 5 prozent oder
vier geräten geblieben aber durch diese
unzufrieden und das ist versagten der
pan aktuellen politik war das dann so zu
erwarten
ich bin als im krieg geboren und man hat
gesehen wie deutschland wächst und was
jetzt letztendlich dann wieder daten
könnte erschreckend einfach erschreckend
neuer wind im rathaus den vorhandenen
polit laden mal aufzumischen von inneres
ist sinnvoll nur halt mit nicht mit
rechtsnationalen
hintergrund die stimme verluste von der
cdu sind die stimmenverluste von der
meldung
sie lässt die anderen gar nicht zu wort
kommen hat ihre eigene meinung und macht
nur so wie sie will und nicht an dass
sie weicht nicht abschießt keine
kompromisse mit den leuten auch in der
politik nicht und was ihr nicht gefällt
schickt sie nach brüssel oder zu wahren
das hin verbannen
und das ist nicht gut nein sie muss
kompromisse mit allen parteien mit jedem
machen und nicht so ihre linie die sie
hat ja aber es sind ja auf der russe hat
sich die kleinen dinge auch also dass
kein arzt in der nähe ist dass schulen
geschlossen werden dass die in der nähe
der polnischen grenze sagen die ist ja
überhaupt nicht gesichert wird
der clown sehr inzwischen ganze pferde
herden und und kuhherden und sowas sind
das nicht eine summe auch oft dieser
kleinen verunsicherung gar nicht diese
großen themen in der afg fließt vieles
an alltäglichen problemen auch am
aufgestauter unzufrieden mit dem
deutschen politischen system zusammen
die flüchtlings thematik war lediglich
der große katalysator schauen sie seit
der wiedervereinigung messen wir
demoskopisch in den neuen bundesländern
wesentlich geringeres vertrauen zum
politischen system und zum politischen
personal also in den altbundesländern
ständig ist ein entführungs bereitschaft
da gewesen früher konnte sie sich im
wähler und der pds entladen als die pds
zu einer normalen deutschen linken
partei wurde ja dann konnte man jene
sondern die sich dann um die zuwanderung
und um die bewahrung nationale identität
herum entfaltet haben nicht mehr
auffangen
sahra wagenknecht eine der klügsten
ihrer ganzen partei hat das begriffen
oskar lafontaine auch weswegen sie
sozusagen als die afd länder linkspartei
diskreditiert werden
hinzu kommt das eben im osten
gravierende probleme da sind schauen sie
werden in einem dicht in einem dünn
besiedelten gebiet der demografische
wandel zu schlägt also die bevölkerung
sich aus sind dann bin ich irgendwann
auch der infrastruktur aus der mensch
geht der wolf kommt könnte man das ganze
zugespitzt sagen dann erlebt man im
osten zwar dass die straßen schön werden
und die gebäude schön sind aber man weiß
dass es nicht eine im lande selbst
erwirtschaften wirtschaftskraft
ist die wertschöpfung im osten liegt aus
verschiedenen gründen immer noch
deutlich unter der im westen
es hat kein großes unternehmen im osten
seinen sitz folglich fließende steuern
dort nicht hin
die zuschüsse aus dem bundeshaushalt
gehe irgendwann zurückkommen ist auf den
normalen horizontalen finanzausgleich
angewiesen folglich spart man also es
ist so geil jetzt greife ich mal ein
ist das nicht der jammer ossi nein also
herr patzelt hat sie sich für sich
gesprochen sondern hat nachhinein das
war ja auch nicht jemand was sie da
beschrieben haben auch mit mit
ärztemangel im ländlichen raum und so
weiter also mit verlaub ich habe
zufälligerweise zu wahlkampfzeiten eine
fahrradtour auch durchgang gemacht da
haben sie die gleichen plakate auch
gesehen von parteien die diese stimmung
aufgenommen haben die gesagt haben wir
haben hier keine ärzte wir haben hier
keine infrastruktur mehr also das ist
kein rein ostdeutsches phänomen sondern
ein phänomen des ländlichen raumes so
punkt 1.2
ich sträube mich stark gegen diese
stigmatisierung die dann ja manchmal
sogar noch mit seinem single einher geht
das jetzt aus dem westen heraus gesagt
hat der ostdeutsche man ja also ich
meine ja wir haben uns aus guten gründen
verknüpfen zu sagen der russe der türke
er weiß ich nicht plötzlich sagen jetzt
der ostdeutsche man im singular als ob
das irgendwie so eine fiese pflegen
hilfreich ist da so nennt 1 noch dass er
sagt ich war vor einigen tagen
zufälligerweise habe ich dieter althaus
getroffen im früheren höchster präsident
von thüringen wir hatten mal ein ganz
anderes erklärungsmuster als dieses die
die doofen aus ihrem da noch besonders
die männer genannt er hat gesagt wir
müssen verstehen die menschen im osten
sind jahrzehntelang von einer regierung
ja drangsaliert werden die ihnen eine
nix für ein u vorgemacht hat und dann
kam als die wiedervereinigung kommt
regierungsvertreter die ihnen eine nix
für ein u vorgemacht
diese bevölkerung ist extrem sensibel
wenn sie das gefühl hat ihn wird ein iks
für ein u vorgemacht so gesehen und das
war in fragende gration
flüchtlingspolitik klar der fall war
angela merkel so gesehen ist das keine
antidemokratische haltung die sich da
manifestiert sondern eine sehr
demokratisch so dann frage ich sie herr
ständige also sozusagen als im westen
wohnen da wie auch ich
hat denn das fast schon das ist richtig
tief ist ja aber es gehe jetzt mal noch
weiter in den westen nämlich in saal an
ja da hat herr altmaier nun erklärt es
ist besser nicht zu wählen als die afg
zu wählen
das ist doch dann es also der altmaier
ist für seine worte selbst zuständig ich
glaube er hat damit noch mal
wahlkampfhilfe für die partei betrieben
die er damit eigentlich schädigen wollte
bei dem satz 5 2
es gab ja dahinter er hinterher auch
einiges gerede darüber dass ihm das in
den mund gelegt wurde
nein er hätte es vermeiden können diese
aussage das war nicht die bild zeitung
reingelegt hat sondern er hat letzten
endes sie haben gesagt grotesk das ist
natürlich grotesk die ganze zeit
predigen wir das doch bitte die
wahlbeteiligung steigern möge und dass
bitte die leute zu den wahlen gehen wir
geben geld für entsprechende gute
kampagnen aus und dann sagt jemand ja
aber wenn ihr welt - die parteien die
uns gefallen und andere nicht an dieser
stelle übrigens ist etwas vom
dramatischen dieser ganzen
innerdeutschen konflikte zu sehen
schauen sie das ist die tatsache dass
die ostdeutsche wirtschaft und
gesellschaft und zum teil auch politik
zumindest die ministerialverwaltung von
einer westdeutschen oberschicht
überlagert und überformt ist jene
westdeutsche oberschicht die den
ostdeutschen sagt wie man richtig denken
wie man richtig argumentiert die in der
sache recht hat und moralisch besser ist
aber schon aufgegeben dass er war in der
in der wiedervereinigung zeit zu
vermeiden schwenkte sie schenkt es ist
nicht alleine sie reden auch nicht das
sächsische jahren sind freunde es lässt
ja ja das argument zu ende führen dass
es eine beschreiben warum ist so
gekommen ist liegt ja auf der hand die
folge ist aber dass ostdeutsche sich nun
von dieser neuen westdeutschen
oberschicht insbesondere weil sie auch
im kulturellen diskurs im politischen
diskurs tonangebend gibt überformt und
von axon stadt von y versehen sieht und
das ist eine innerdeutsche spaltung die
westdeutschen sind gut die ostdeutschen
sind schlecht die westdeutschen sind
klug die ostdeutschen sind um die
sachsen sind die allerdümmsten war schon
in der ddr waren sie im tal der
ahnungslosen wissen muss
gerade was los ist er gerade die
handreichung versucht als ich gesagt
habe
genauso darf der diskurs nicht laufen
das wird so wird er der sache auch nicht
erreicht aber heute das wird der sache
jetzt zum schluss noch mal kurz gefragt
gerecht wie soll man die afd
im bundestag behandelt meint der extra
schäuble institut analysiert naja ob das
der wahre grund war würde dass wolfgang
schäuble norbert lammert als
bundestagspräsident vorsitz das kann man
mal dahin gestellt sein sie muss in der
sache hart aber im ton fair behandelt
werden alles andere schadet und wir
hatten dieser tage von cicero ein
gespräch mit andreas voßkuhle dem
präsidenten des
bundesverfassungsgerichtes der genau auf
diese frage sagt habe man kann und darf
die ard nicht aus dem politischen
diskurs verbannen sondern man muss mit
ihr den brief vorgelesen
diese woche zu hören in der nächsten
ausgabe dann zu lesen oder auch zu sehen
phoenix phoenix hat das übertragen das
ist meines erachtens genau der richtige
ansatz die stigmatisierung bringt gar
nichts die inhaltliche
auseinandersetzung wird sehr viel
bringen wir haben viele dieser parteien
unter dem druck des parlamentarismus
dann wieder zerbröseln sehen und das
erste bröseln erleben wir bei der afg ja
schon parlamente sind dafür da jene
debatten die es in der bevölkerung gibt
vorzuspielen vorzuspiegeln bei der
argumente zu verbessern und
stellvertretend für die gesellschaft den
politischen streit zu führen was immer
behauptet worden ist man muss die afg
stellen
und was dann vermieden worden ist der
mit den schmuddelkindern setzt man sich
nicht zusammen im bundestag muss und
kann es geschehen
man muss sich daran halten dass die
regeln realistische demokratie und des
parlamentarismus vernünftig sind es sind
bewährte regeln die eben genau dem
zivilisierten streit ermöglichen
man muss sich an die regeln halten und
soll sie nicht verbiegen und kinder
reihen wie die folgende sollte man ganz
unterlassen wo soll die afg setzen sie
ist eine rechte partei folglich musste
genau dort sitzen wo seit der
französischen revolution rechte parteien
sitzen und wenn das im deutschen
bundestag genau vor der regierungsbank
ist dann ist es so die regierung ist im
übrigen selber schuld dass die afg im
parlament ist und folglich sollte die
fehler ihrer eigenen versäumnisse ja das
habe ich auch gedacht das wäre ja die
höchststrafe überhaupt vier jahre der
fd gegenüber zu sitzen aber den augstein
immerhin also sagen wir mal so ein
antipode von ihnen eigentlich politisch
gesehen der hat gesagt
merkel ist die mutter der afd ja da habe
ich auch gestaunt als jakob augstein das
geschrieben hat ich hatte das vorher
schon vor jahren so formuliert dass sie
diese partei erst groß gemacht hat und
ja dann müssen sie halt jetzt quasi den
sind förmlich riechen die sie nicht
riechen können die ganzen arbeiten sind
denn eng wird es ja auch noch bei 109
bundestags abgaben der größte bundestag
den wir hätten ich glaube jetzt das
zweitgrößte parlament weltweit da
rutscht dieser afd des afg kuchenstück
sehr nah an die regierungsbank aber
bitteschön das soll dann am ende das
geringste übel sein
der streit muss geführt werden ich meine
1 1 haben wir schon erlebt herr kauder
hat vor jahr und tag 2050 gehalt mit
denen setze ich mich nie in eine
talkshow siehe da plötzlich saß herr
kauder mit denen in einer talkshow und
ich fand auch in der elefantenrunde als
hamilton dann dabei war hat sich schon
gezeigt dass die anderen parteien auch
lernen müssen anders und ich würde sagen
besser mit der afg umzugehen
konstruktive kritik aber keine schmähung
unterm strich sieht man demokratie
funktioniert denn demokraten in der
politischen auseinandersetzung versagen
so sorgt der wähler dafür dass sie ihre
gegner dann doch noch ins parlament von
die nase bekommen und so gehört es sich
also dann ist es im endeffekt wenigstens
zum ende unserer sendung keine wähler
beschimpfung dies heute allgemein gibt
sondern ein lob für die demokratische
wahl die wir hatten ganz herzlichen dank
werner patzelt herzlichen dank christoph
schwennicke dass sie beiden da waren das
was für heute wir sehen uns in zwei
wochen wieder
[Musik]